I was at my parents this weekend my dad
and I were talking about how we were
making thirty five thousand dollars a
year in the prime of when I built my
library we made thirty five thousand
dollars a year like every dollar just
went into building it
I told you this was last Monday morning
in your life
just go all in and go out later really
that's not like his words but just if
you're gonna do it do it you know I'm
saying he he keeps it straight up with
me he keeps it real you know I'm saying
up if my ideas or any of our ideas
aren't good enough he's gonna let us
know you know I'm saying you know I
think what me and I can't got going on
we gonna do something big these next few
months few years so it's gonna be good
like what's my advice I'm making money
yeah okay yeah yeah you want to record
it so we can listen you know what I mean
in general I think people need to record
meetings more often I really wanted to
learn how to make money on the off
season cause being in Canada you know we
only get paid to see this I just wanted
to really pick his mind pick his brain
and see what I can do anything I could
do on the side and he really helped me
out with give me some good tips I
recorded our conversation I think that
there's you know there's a couple ways
to think about making money to make
money as an entrepreneur and business
person which I've done you know you
build and you sell stuff you start a
business
there's also you've got enough just
enough level of fame to be you and make
money what does that mean that means and
we can help you with this a little bit
can you get paid two thousand dollars to
give a talk in the northwest that's when
your brand most lives right I think what
you're doing with a team like documented
creating content is numb content is the
absolute gateway to opportunity you know
you can make one video that I feel like
I don't know if you're listening to this
cuz this might be scratchy I don't know
how I clipped it yes I'll do that and
then also we went to a Jets game
yesterday my first NFL game ever
Jetson Patriots are you Tex fans your
team lost but a man
is a good game and had a good time my
guy Gary we appreciate you brother and
AJ and the rest of the guys are you guys
first cousins no we're really really
close for you guys know each other since
we were about five four by you've
adopted cousins how'd you get involved
with this guy right yeah oh we grew up
since we were little kids you know
Jackie Robinson pardon to go back it was
Uncle the same way was this actually
somebody's own yeah man I listen I love
it I love it I mean a hundred percent
that's the way to do it just we have a
we go back high school Pop Warner
football middle school you know college
you know they actually he went to Oregon
and I went to work a state and the
Beavers we just won the Civil War in the
first time like since 2007 so you know
all my beeper fans up there watching
this no we did it all right let me let
me let me let's keep let's keep talking
about this look we're gonna start
working on the talk we're gonna start
working on your website I'm gonna take a
look at that
let me give some a few minutes I'm gonna
keep this so I'm making a few minutes on
this and we'll take it from there dog
it's really impressive my message email
email all right
I came your pleasure yes yeah of course
yeah I know we've been moving in a ton
on them but it's worth it
no okay it's gonna see the rocks I was a
ranger trip good
that's my post game yes yes I Drive just
say you know my speed and Ross put a
link to it they'll understand see ya
d-roc I think just okay Gary I'm super
well no not yesterday was actually
perfect get out he's the best the best
yeah we're uh you know you you know you
you put five hundred twenty seven point
nine year olds together and yet you get
some serious energy you probably feel
this too right like like it's
unbelievable how much an organization
will actually take the exact personality
of its leaner I think it's a stunning
misunderstanding like if your company
sucks your leader sucks like that's just
real because she or he is in charge they
can get rid of all the bad stuff they
I hate when leaders are like oh it's
Rick's lot like you hired Rick [ __ ]
you know
Annie video video video video video
video video like like 1.7 million on the
61 seconds what's the best way to get me
to make captions cuz that's what's
holding us up yeah okay
that bacon sorrow got it okay first I
trust you on that let them go in that
says you have I connected to you again
you need copy for Facebook yeah
another thing do you think I'm right
about not putting too many if I'm gonna
build up the LAV I think too much
content is gonna not make people want to
be subscribed so I think what we should
be on YouTube you know like yeah there's
a bunch of that there thing sometimes
talked about we've talked about
everything a lot do you think that if
we're making this commitment to daily be
that we should maybe only put two videos
a day max and what we do is then use I
think we can get away with two to three
one of them always being gay TV so like
you I want to go to I believe in I'm
right about by seeing one being able to
be one being something else and we have
to do that like we should almost do one
of those every day all good stuff man
how are you oh but you were you were you
were here when we meet here no Jesus
weather weather yeah a hundred percent
especially for me I'm like hustle for
New York
so like LA feels like but but the
weather can seduce you
the weather can trick you the weather
don't let the weather trick you the snow
Linds I need to talk to you about don't
let me forget about yeah it was really
good all right I guess I'll take it off
propose this it's made sense first quite
some time that just you two get together
have different reasons hey Charlie
selfish master fan of what you've done
everywhere I friendly well let me see
what you've done - Ian's for a while now
so I think for us it just makes sense to
get together star of daily b-52 or
whatever I know like partnership
opportunity between both of you and I
think like whether it's like us being
able to like connect you with like
central clients for being our talent or
like you know it's talking to you about
we're looking to do with video or any
platform fans I just think there's like
a lot of opportunities to partner um I'm
sure we're both here for the same reason
which it especially just knowing what I
know about you from afar and just
knowing these people so well and what
they feel I you know it's gonna be a
game of like the other person trying to
provide you know like value right you
know from my standpoint I'd love to know
everything that like I'd love to know
the three most important things for you
in the world and like you know and I
think you you you definitely know this
and all of you know this like if video
is important to you I don't need you
guys to become a client if you want to
come here and or actually it's at 3:15
actually it's about to be in Long Long
Island City like from my standpoint I'm
just playing forever you know and so
that's you know what I mean and so for
me I have zero short-term wants yes
I mean Boehner towns super important so
we have a real thing that we're about to
build so that's good and cool but as far
as from your guys world any capability
that you guys want internally I'm
thrilled to lift the you know the hood
and
okay you can figure out which probably
the facebook video version versus the
CNN documentary okay I don't know 40 oh
great that's a lot it's a big one yep I
wasn't so much of these guys she started
I had a public-access TV show no [ __ ]
yeah channel 35 I loved it but it was on
my high school sports day I grew up in
an IB well we did like with video how
old are you about I'm 48 for love it you
just turned 44 yeah when it's impressive
I'm November 14th and I've already
accepted 41 but grudgingly go ahead
you know what my LLC is called my
personal LLC the thing I run everything
through filling the seats oh [ __ ]
because in now I'm gonna tell you a
story about Tribeca
because in 2005 drew from Tribeca Bar
and Grill reaches I know and he goes hey
I hear you're like the new whiz kid of
wine we have this $200 wine dinner that
we've sold three seats for and I have to
sell 190 of them can you help and I'm
like I'm like me I don't maybe I had
never was thinking I'm selling wine I'm
a wine retailer in New Jersey so I send
an email to my wine email newsletter I
have no idea what's gonna happen and I
get a phone call from Tribeca Bar and
Grille I said the email 11th I remember
this like yesterday at 11:30 in the
morning at 1217 they call me I get on
the phone they go what the [ __ ] did you
do and I said I sent an email to my
email newsletter they're like we've sold
out we've spent mailers like signage
like calling people
you've sold out 140 seats I literally
called my accountant I'm like I need you
to register an LLC to filling the seats
that's why it's filling the seats so
let's continue this real pleasure
have a great great holiday try to see
before the end of year great to see you
we're okay good
to where
great day hustle got a lot done it was
good to get back in the grind after ten
days of filming in LA and Thanksgiving
weekend really enjoying the seven days a
week
dailyvee hope you guys are as well and I
will see you soon
you